do people understand
the likelihood of a national abortion ban in the next few years
like even if Republicans don't control Congress
there's a few different ways that this could play out
let me explain first thing they're gonna try to use is the Comstock Act
The Comstock Act is a law from the 1800s
that prohibited you from mailing obscene matter
including contraception and any tools that could be used to procure an abortion
The Comstock act was the product of this weirdo narc named Anthony Comstock
who was obsessed with trying to eradicate corn
birth control and abortion throughout the United States
we've really come full circle here
cause that's also kind of the modern day Republican Party
see the Comstock Act just kind of like floated into oblivion where it belongs
it was never actually repealed
so it's a law that's still on the books in the United States
Republicans are currently trying to revive the Comstock Act
particularly in the mifepristone litigation
where they are arguing that abortion pills can't be sent through the mail
because it's prohibited under the Comstock Act
this is just the starting point for conservatives
who are trying to find a court that will hold that this 150 year old law
can be used to prohibit abortion pills today
and that the law is constitutional
given uphill battle because the law is pretty clearly unconstitutionally vague
it bans sending any obscene matter through the US Postal Service
which doesn't really give citizens any idea
of what is and is not prohibited under the act
but I've seen some really wild opinions by Trump appointed judges
so you can really never be sure at this point
If they succeed at finding a court that will rely on the Comstock Act
they're gonna go in after birth control under the act
and then they're going to try to eradicate abortion nationwide
by relying on the act's provision
that it prohibits any tools that are being sent through the mail
to procure an abortion
so they'll just try to start banning a bunch of medical tools
remember this is a law that's already on the book
so if Trump wins
he wouldn't necessarily need Congress to help him affectuate this plan
second thing they're gonna try to do is argue that the FDA
and other federal agencies screwed up when they approved medication
abortion and abortion procedures
and it's actually just really unsafe for women
and we're just really looking out for women to go
watch my video on the Chevron doctrine
to fully understand the intricacies of how this one will play out
but basically earlier this week
the Supreme Court gave a green light for courts to second guess federal agencies
like the FDA so just as in the mifipristone litigation
plaintiffs are arguing that look
the FDA screwed up when it approved mifipristone
a commonly used unsafe abortion medication
which is safer than penicillin
tylenol and Viagra
and they're trying to find anti choice
extremist judges to be like yeah
I am wiser than the FDA the expert scientists and doctors at the FDA
and I will second guess them and take mifepristone off the market
if they succeed at that they'll try to start doing that
for methods of birth control and other methods of procuring an abortion
and the last option
is that Republicans are just going to try to pass a national abortion ban
depending on how much control they have of Congress and the presidency
this whole idea like
let's just leave it to the states
yeah um
they are lying to you they absolutely want a national abortion ban
so yeah
um not to scare everybody
but this is the practical reality that we need to understand and plan for
and fight against
and I think a lot of people who live in blue states feel pretty safe
like they don't feel like an abortion ban is gonna come to them
but as I just explained there's multiple avenues that it may come to you
and they're actively trying to affectuate them
like yesterday
this is everything I just described is already happening